hanging pictures for a new exhibition
but Arthur Heller has run her own
gallery in Cobourg for 20 years from
time to time she attracts international
artists here
my name is Beata hello I'm from the
beautiful city of Kobo but I grew up
here I was away for ten years and like
so many of my contemporaries I've
returned here my family is also here my
son grew up here just like me and
cobourg is colorful lively and very
likeable with her gallery
Piazza Heller contributes to making
cobourg a lively place she's turned a
former coach house into a popular event
venue
Quahog has plenty of historical flair
with its narrow streets and
half-timbered facades the gallery owners
first recommendation takes us to a
central meeting place for the locals the
Market Square has existed since the
early 15th century
and you'll find lots of historical
references here core bugs Market Square
where we're now standing could be called
the urban center it's where seven narrow
streets meet I know there used to be two
trade routes that crossed here one from
Nuremberg to effort and one from Prague
to Frankfurt mine mine
those times are long past but you only
have to go a few meters to find some
culinary traditions cobalt dumplings are
a local delicacy they're famous for
their soft consistency and suitable for
the youngest of gourmets traditional eco
burgers get their dumplings right after
they're weaned because they're easy to
eat so we grow up with them after some
hearty foods it's time to head for the
art his next recommendation she takes us
on a stroll through the court garden
with her dog Lily it's a large landscape
Park which was begun in the mid 17th
century and took more or less 200 years
to reach its present-day form the parks
basic layout is based on strictly
geometrical patterns the rose garden is
a cozy retreat this is my favorite place
in the park the small rose garden here
you can escape the noise of the city
meet during your lunch break talk to
friends and walk up to the castle and
here it is a hundred and sixty meters
above the town cobalt Castle is one of
the best preserved fortress complexes in
Germany the 13th century castle houses a
large and varied art collection
it includes the marquetry room with
hunting scenes in wood inlay and a
historical tiled stove she's warming her
rear on a tiled stove that's funny
these treasures once belonged to the
Dukes of Cobourg they're part of one of
the most important historical art
collections in Germany
i'm kang gyunseong Leontine you can take
a guided tour here but you can also look
around on your own up here there are art
collections knight's armor lots of
paintings mutters room that's where
Martin lotta once lived and worked but
arta hella discovered the castle early
on it's cute as a child I always
imagined what it would be like to be
shut in here in leavening then I could
really run riot and explore the castle
for myself
cobalt Castle a fascinating destination
and you're certain to meet some of the
locals here as well